[Music]
Rebecca Rebecca I had a dream I need to
build a two-man RV camper handcart and
take the boys on a grand adventure Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everyone slide over the top of Nate he's
got a helmet on it's okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well there we go
she's all painted I even opted for the
undercarriage coating yeah all right
guys you ready we're going down the
driveway and I'm using my butt brake
yeah this piece of leather back here
just lean into it and that makes it so
you don't have to use your arms to slow
down the cart and that is a big deal
[Music]
all right guys I'm really glad we did
this test height because it exposed a
couple design flaws first off the
handles the boys were sitting in the
cart and it was tipped back like this
and one of them stepped forward and went
boom like that and it cracked the wood
right there you can see it just barely
hanging on by a thread
additionally back here we don't have
enough clearance you can see right here
all along here yeah we keep hitting
rocks when you're going uphill and
you're getting tired you tend to hike
the handles up and lean into it to get
more power and that makes the backend go
down and I start clipping rocks
additionally this thing shakes and
shimmies a lot
the boys are complaining that they're
getting headaches so we need to do some
sort of shock absorbing we need to fix
the handles and we need to increase our
clearance we've been thinking about it
we've come up with some great solutions
and I'm really excited about the changes
we're gonna make unfortunately we've got
to redo the entire project but is it
gonna be worth it yeah yeah we'll be
let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so the boys are complaining a lot about
the balancing and I wanted to put shocks
on this thing but it was just way too
complicated so instead I spent 8 bucks
and got these three inch foam pads for
sitting up in your deer stand and I
figured those would be a decent solution
so we're gonna put those in here so what
do you think but I is that pretty cool
well I'm liking this car a lot more it's
heavier but there's a lot less play and
wiggle in it and there's the clearance
isn't a problem anymore and the boys get
to sit upright and enjoyed themselves a
little bit more and it's a lot more
comfortable they're not in a big pile in
the bottom of the cart okay let's try
the kickstand see if it works yeah if
it's flat its silky smooth well this is
nice cuz the handles are higher I can
lean against the door and get the brake
the same way I did with that leather
strap only without having a leather
strap in the way
[Music]
well my paint sprayer just busted so
we're gonna be doing this by hand
[Music]
[Music]
put a window in it this is a $10 doggie
window off of amazon.com you kind of
hold on your fence and put it in there
so your dog can look out at the world
now it'll feel a little bit less like a
coffin to the person in the bottom of
the handcart
now put some white lithium grease in
here whoo all right it's done
the handcarts built now let me show you
how this thing turns into a two-man
camper check this out okay
first go and take the seats out then we
didn't clip it all right there we go
this is the first bed it's six foot six
inches by 23 and a half inches that's
slightly larger than the standard
camping pad and camping bag okay next
gonna take off the wheel you got both
wheels off kind of find a nice level
spot here and then we grab this these
are some of those anti fatigue pads you
get at the hardware store there we go
this is six-and-a-half feet long 24
inches wide
once again slightly larger than the
standard dimensions of a sleeping bag
there you go guys got bunk beds look at
that
if you like that
you think you'd be dry if it rained can
the wind get in there we go we got the
bottom bed and we got a top bed with two
boys at it because the hand carps kind
of a weird shape just go and you kind of
roll it up and then just take one of
these little spring clips and clip it
and it makes a little bit tighter if
it's windy there's still room to put
some of your gear outside the handcart
but under the tarp or if there's just
one of you you can sleep down on the
bottom or the top and put your gear in
the other spot but there we have it a
two-man RV camper handcart made from
wood and some tires and stuff all right
guys it's moment of truth let's go
camping with this thing Jacob are you
excited to go camping
Nate Jake and me are given this handcart
a full trial run we've got camping gear
and enough food for at least one night
or two
we've got fishing gear we're gonna go
hiking and exploring and we're just
gonna see what it's like we're gonna see
if everything works the way it should
you guys excited
[Applause]
I'm so glad Jake gets to come along this
is a perfect trip for a light little guy
[Music]
well I just walked my first mile with
the handcart my arms are a little warm
but it's not bad and the gravels not
shaking us up too much hey guys you
ready to go through a tunnel well I've
tried every which way but I can't get
the axle out and I can't get it through
the door with the axle on so we're gonna
have to go around I'm more than a little
disappointed we couldn't fit the car
through that door but we still gonna
walk through the tunnel and check it out
all right let's go oh it's dark in here
so we turn on the light check it out
inside this tunnel wall getting wet a
lot of a lot of water coming down there
is this scary guys here hold hold hands
is neat
there you go you guys do it okay yeah
well we've been walking forever all this
water from the ceiling oh I'm getting
rained on look at that oh yeah there's
water coming out yeah you barely see the
beginning there we did it we walked
three-fifths of a mile under a mountain
and we crossed a Continental Divide on
this side of the tunnel all the water
flows into the Atlantic Ocean
on the other side of the tunnel all the
water flows into the Gulf of Mexico
that's kind of cool well it's it listen
we gotta go back and get the cart and
see if we can find the way around okay
come on let's go back
oh I wish I could get the cart through
that stupid door echo all right watch
your head
all right guys do you want to get some
lunch now go bring me a bunch of sticks
and I'll use it to cook the little lunch
[Music]
reel them up whoa keep reading them oh
you're that oh that is a big green
sunfish that is a big one put them back
in the water high five yeah in case you
don't know what this is this is my
homemade rocket stove if you want to see
how to make it I did a whole video on
these I'll put a link in the description
all right well the kids are gonna finish
up lunch in the cart and we're gonna
double back and see if we can find a way
around this tunnel
alright guys we're here it let's get
going well it took a lot of effort and a
little off-roading in the Kia but we are
on the other side of the tunnel and once
again we're on the trail along the canal
system this trail is the C&O canal trail
it's a hundred and eighty five mile long
trail that goes from Western Maryland
all the way to DC and it shadows the
Potomac River was a way for boats to get
up over the falls and you can see here
to my right is the remnants of the canal
and when we're walking on is the towpath
they would hook up a donkey some horses
to the barges and they would pull the
barges along the canal and it is a
beautiful hiking trail we're gonna just
keep going along this and I wanna see
what there is to see
do you saw an alligator Jacob this right
here that is a Morel that is a very
delicious and rare mushroom right there
you know see this we go we'll go put it
in the pot there and save it well that
was a fun surprise we need to find some
more of those those morels are very
sought-after and very expensive I'm
gonna keep my eye out for more of those
I just stopped the car a little bit
because I saw something that'll go good
with our Morel we got some field garlic
here right there there we go Oh tix I'm
doing the bulbs the best part but you
can eat this as well keep moving
pretty why pull in for another hour and
man my arms a little tender but I'm
having a great time at the river right
there and gorgeous scenery all around
look at this weather's perfect
are you guys having fun you thirsty
buddy
yeah yeah yeah all right should we keep
going let's keep exploring Ted a wild
turkey run out in front of us and take
off that was cool this is one of the
locks on the canal the boat would sail
into here and they would shut a gate
there and open a gate there and it would
fill it with water and the boat would
get higher then they would open up that
gate and it would keep sailing it's like
a staircase but with boats and this is
one of the stair steps well the Sun
started to get a little low and I've
done five miles and I've got another
mile to go my back's good my legs good
but my arms are getting tired so I think
I might try dogging a little bit see if
that helps do you want sport mode Jacob
the doggie isn't that bad on the arms
but my cardio is garbage Oh
the problem is Jacob likes it so much he
keeps screaming sperm Oh daddy well I
took some work but I think we made it to
where a place where we can stay the
night oh is this like a nice place to
camp
why don't you go grab it gather up some
firewood take all the firewood and put
it right here in the fire ring okay all
right I'll get dinner made and start
setting up camp well I got the handcart
mostly converted over to sleep mode I'll
do the rest of it when the boys get
tucked into bed we need to get some
dinner hey guys what do you want to eat
we've got spaghetti with meat sauce beef
stew I'm gonna try the pad thai here
okay and I've got a whole bunch of
saltine crackers to fill it out I saw I
bought along this pack of survival
rations this is 2,400 calories each one
of these little packages is 240 calories
so two of those packages are about the
equivalent of one of these mountain
house meals I'm a big boy and I just
pulled a lot of kids I need to I need to
load up on some calories there you go
all right we're boiling let's get Dinner
started you guys having fun playing in
the card take the cracker and scoop some
up and then y'all done Jacob if you guys
watch my videos you know I love these
adhesive body warmers they're great for
taking kids camp
and fishing just got these stickers on
them and you just stick them to the
outside of their jammies like that and
then they last 12 hours so these will
keep the boys nice and warm all night
long give inside your sleeping bag you
guys doing good in there yeah never
gotta go to bed all right got the rain
fly up got all her gear covered now if
only we can get them to go to bed that
would really be something well it looks
like the boys are finally asleep
oh it's a long day and I am gonna be
sore in the morning I hauled all my
fishing gear all the way here I'm
camping by a river not even using it I'm
so tired I'm just gonna go to bed
all right guys I'll see you in the
morning oh it smells like pad thai farts
in there asleep and all the time here
this bunk bed he got out of his bed and
smashed his head City open you like pee
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what do you think of the dehydrogenase
it's a way high [ __ ] alright guys you
ready to go do some more exploring well
listen we're gonna keep heading down the
trail there's a number of locks and a
waterfall and a little canyon and we're
gonna go all the way to the end of the
tunnel that we had to turn back at
earlier well I was worried about being
sore this morning but I'm doing really
good we got 8 and a half miles today so
I think we're gonna be alright
I'm a little worried about those clouds
off in the horizon I look like we're
gonna get rained on but we've got rain
gear and I can put the top on the
handcar keep the kids dry the gear dry
we got the package secured
we finally made it to the other side of
the tunnel this has been absolutely
wonderful I've had so much fun and it's
just been gorgeous it's totally exceeded
my expectations this is really my first
time hiking the CNO canal trail we only
did ten and a half miles of it there's a
hundred and eighty-five miles of this
trail from Cumberland to DC and I think
it'd be so much fun to take the whole
family and do this camping and biking
the entire length of the trail if that's
something you guys would like to see
make sure to click like and subscribe to
let me know that that's something you
want to see more of well it's been a fun
little rest but we've got to do seven
and a half miles back to the car you
guys ready all right and this has been
so much fun
Nathan I think I need to apologize to
you it turns out that socks do grow on
trees look at that
[Music]
take it out that's from a turkey
[Music]
whoo-hoo I'm sore but we had a good time
I hope you guys enjoyed this as much as
we did you want to see more great videos
from the outdoor boys YouTube channel
check out our fishing cabin video where
we built from scratch a floating fishing
cabin and all of our many many other
survival and camping videos we will put
a playlist in the video description
check them all out there loads of fun
thanks for watching and don't forget to
click subscribe we put out new videos
every Saturday morning see you guys
later if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor boys
youtube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like that and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning and hit that Bell button and
you'll get notifications thanks for
watch
[Music]